welcome back to the David Pakman show.
All right, let's go back to the phones at
(617) 830-4750.
Let's see,
talk to, let's talk to you and repay from
Los Angeles.
What's going on today?
Okay.
Hey David, how's it going man?
Good, how are you?
Good, thanks.
So again, thanks for [inaudible].
You're amazing.
I wrote down a couple of things as time.
Number One, I think, uh, I think what Trump
is doing at the border is I'm totally on purpose
and it's a distraction.
And, uh, I think this was just a, like a big
plan, um, and doing all this crazy stuff so
that Democrats go and do what we always do
and go crazy and you know, do what the squad
doing and, you know, go on TV and talk about
the horrible things that are happening.
Yeah.
I really think Trump is not intelligent like
when it comes to policy and reading and all
that stuff, but he is really good at like
sales and manipulation and all that.
So I really think that we need to be against
what he's doing, but we need to talk about
like the issues that the vast majority of
Americans are worried about because I think
that it's a huge distraction.
It really is.
Hispanic American, myself.
It's a huge distraction and words and it sits
incredible.
Number two.
Um, what else?
I think that,
well, let me talk about that.
I mean, there's a lot there, Enrique, that
I want to address.
I think you're basically correct and what
you pointed out that's really important is
when we say something is a distraction by
Trump, we don't mean that.
It doesn't matter.
Right?
So as you're pointing out, what Trump's doing
at the border is disgusting.
It's really affecting people's lives.
It's affecting American lives, it's affecting
the lives of people from other countries.
It's disgusting and an absolute disaster.
And he's a total ignoramus when it comes to
policy.
And we should be opposed to what he's doing.
At the same time, we should make sure that
our reactions don't give him a win by number
one, dividing the left in ways that are counterproductive.
Number two, getting his actual other scandals
out of the, the new cycle.
So as an example, over the weekend when he
said, you know, the four Congress women need
to go back to their original countries, it
made it so there was no coverage over the
weekend of the growing links between Trump
and Jeffrey Epstein, who's been accused of
serial child sex trafficking and all this
other stuff.
So you're, you're astutely pointing out, just
because it's a distraction which Trump is
good at, doesn't mean that what he's doing
doesn't require our opposition.
It does.
But we need to be thoughtful in how we oppose
it.
Yeah.
And that's why I think like the top leadership,
like Polosi she's, you know, she's, she's
skilled and she's a, she's a master politician
herself.
That's why she doesn't go all crazy like a
ALC.
And you know, which I think what's going on
is horrible.
But I think that they should just say, look,
this is a horrible issue and we need to deal
with it the way, like, just, we need to set
it to default.
Like this is America.
We have standards, there are no human rights
violations here.
And we're going to deal with it that way.
And the story,
but don't make it, we should say, we should
not allow human.
And you're not saying that there aren't any
going on.
You're saying they are going on and we got
it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's it.
But that's basic.
We've already dealt with that.
That's an old thing.
America just doesn't do this right.
And let's move on, right.
Number two, I think that, um, what's happening
with Trump I think is really dangerous.
Um, I think it is very scary.
And this is gonna sound crazy.
But when Obama got elected in Hawaii, I was
really worried because the way my mind works,
really, I'm not kidding.
Like I told my brother, me and my brother
talking about politics all the time and I
said, you know what?
This is bad.
And he was like, why?
This is great.
I was like, yeah, I know it's great, but it's,
it's bad in a way because it's gonna rile
up a lot of people and a lot of people aren't
ready for this.
And I think that Trump is just, uh, you know,
the, the aftermath of that.
That's just my thing.
Well, listen, I think, I think the country
was ready for Barack Obama.
I think no matter when we had our first half
black president, there was going to be a group
that was radicalized and activated by that.
I think you're right that the timing when
Donald Trump said, hey, I'm gonna run for
president was unfortunate timing, but I think
the country was ready for Barack Obama.
Right, right.
I mean, yeah.
Yeah.
But it does just mean like I thought like
it was going to cause some backlash against
Brown people.
That's just, it was very basic in my mind.
I was like, this is going to hurt Brown people
like and Brown Americans in the end.
And another thing is a really quick uh, talking
about like going back to the thing about Tom
Squares, I always wanted to say something
about that.
I really don't think that you too, um, is
like the town square.
You know Joe Rogan was talking about like,
yeah, like um, you know, freedom of speech.
I really don't think it's that way on the
Internet because when you have a town square
meeting with citizens, you know, Coca Cola
isn't advertising at that town square.
You know what I mean?
So
not to mention at a town square meeting, you
often do have to pre-submit your questions.
Only a certain number of people get to talk.
There's a limited amount of time.
There's a limited number of seats.
So, I mean, I think that you're right that
using the town square analogy or town hall
analogy, we can find ways in which there is
certainly, it's certainly okay to allow a
platform to have rules.
I think my biggest concern now, and Enrique,
I'm woman of wrap up to this cause I've got
a few other people to talk to you.
My concern is that youtube is not actually
enforcing their own rules in a way that is
fair.
Not the fact that the, the fact that they
have rules is not the problem.
It's that they're enforcing them in a way
that is very unfair.
Hey David and one last thing.
I think all progressors like you convinced
you to it and all that, you guys should all
unite and create one channel
like Fox.
Yeah, no, I know people say that.
There are some complexities about that, but
it's, it's an idea and recap.
I appreciate the call.
Great to hear from you again.
Alright, take care.